massive or will he take it to a longer
game
okay I was gonna say is it the Kingsport
opening which he's been going towards
lately a lot nope it's 1d4
evanchook he plays every opening Under
the Sun every opening known to man what
are we gonna see in his final game the
tournament I predict the night is going
to move out
um oh no I got that wrong oh a little
bit look at this it's a London system
and uh well
and you guys you guys aren't londoners
are you at all yeah
I lived in London for a while but not uh
not born there no yeah I was born in
London oh I wasn't born there no I
thought you meant do you play the London
system so the drop of London system I do
and the London system I lived in London
for a while so yeah yeah near Croydon
yeah
what was the uh Road name uh
that's enough about the London city
I'm a kind but I do remember but yeah
it's uh no but uh back to the London
system the London opening okay we see a
quick porn Exchange
um it's funny I was actually playing a
Blitz game yesterday just to warm up
before the show and I think I had this
exact position on the board on the white
side and I had no idea what to do I
ended up in a draw
um okay White's porn now white C
pornos gonna say is unlikely to push
forward
what do you think of this approach Simon
as The Londoner London system player
well it's not normal uh because uh the
the pawn that Lev basically exchanged is
normally
um your main Pawn which you keep in the
London system so he's playing it in a
bit of a unique way but this push that
he's done with that pawn the C Pawn uh
brings it back into a pretty pretty
normal territory and he's just going for
a small Advantage small positional
Advantage here if he can exchange pawns
he might give himself what we call an
isolated Pawn that he can play against
so a bit of a unique approach anyway
this in the London system not not your
normal Club players approach really no I
mean I have to say I was once told that
you know if if black develops a dark
Square bishop and you capture the pawn
as what's happened in the game and while
it does have a slightly bigger Edge than
you think it does you know you would
think that cable black has got no
problems but there are some problems and
it's mainly based on this light Square
Bishop that black has it just doesn't
have a good diagonal at the minute and
white will just develop normally and
then put the Rooks towards the center no
I say that and he captures the pawn in
the middle
but okay this is another small advantage
that white has and now white will just
start using the strategies that you use
when you face again you you faced at
this pawn and that is first of all you
develop and then you start controlling
the square in front
he continues developing ironian and I'm
assuming levantra called Castle his King
get that piece to safety
yeah it's always hard to say how much of
an advantage there is for white in these
types of scenarios okay he brings this
bishop out that hints at the desire to
want to change the pawn structure
actually Levon aronian maybe he'll
capture this Knight with his Bishop at
some point
um he's flexing there typical 11 Iranian
uh when he likes his position he tends
to stretch uh Black's Bishop coming out
the one kind of negative for me in this
game so far is evantric it's going to be
very hard to win for him it feels like
black is trying to equalize and
this means that we're unlikely to see
him have any chance to qualify for those
Knockouts he's playing great chess I
mean very solid very correct opening but
and less Levon uh kind of provokes him
somehow takes too many risks it's going
to be hard for black to win this game
yeah okay will White Castle his King
finally will he
move his Queen will he nudge that Bishop
that's just developed
it's all about that isolated Queen's
porn for black
at the moment it looks pretty good it
looks like a space Gainer rather than a
weakness yeah I suspect that probably
he'll just Castle
um
you know the black pawn in the middle
it's not threatening to come forward at
any time so
follow the rules of chess the classical
rules that is and just Castle the king
get it out of danger
are you impressed by the speed with
which both players both players are
currently playing because I mean the
last few games at least both of these
players they've played incredibly quick
normally that goes the other way as the
tournament goes on no I I don't I'm not
impressed by the speed
I think it's a dangerous thing yes you
know it can put pressure on your
opponent but as you say things can go
wrong and well he attacks the bishop
takes a step back now castles yay a bit
surprised where white where whites put
his light Square Bishop though this is
the one thing that surprised me I mean
it looks a little bit strange that light
Square Bishop I mean
Black's got a very nice pin what we call
a pin with his Bishop against White's
Knight tying down that Knight and that's
really annoying for white because white
would like to move that Knight and you
don't want to be tied down and it seems
to me that the ideal Square for a light
Square Bishop is to block that pin so
moving it even back here would probably
be the move I'd play because I just want
to swap pieces off
I want to control the square in front of
my opponent's isolated Pawn we say that
pawn in the middle Black's Pawn in the
middle is isolated because again it's a
bit like we talked about porny no mates
earlier the pawn which has no other
pawns next to it which can help it out
and that pawn can never be defended by
another Pawn so it's a weakness and the
square in front of that pawn is the very
big weakness switch I think spassky
again have said this before but spassky
said it's not the pawn it's the square
in front of it so this kind of plan is
very normal you try to exchange pieces
put us put a piece in front that pawn
and later on you try to win that pawn so
that's just what surprises me about this
position where the where the light
Square Bishop is for Iranian at the
moment since the unusual way of stopping
that pawn from advancing
um yeah I just said Simon is to go back
didn't you call the pawn Dilly no mates
I think there was a deep one we called
Dilly yeah yeah in one of the other
shows we called it deep the Deep porn we
gave the name Dilly didn't we yeah Billy
no mates I think it was Dilly no mate
yeah so and uh okay black slides The
Rook
across
but now maybe there are some ideas that
blacks pieces are gonna get active and I
kind of agree with you there Simon that
that Bishop is on the wrong diagonal and
it's on the wrong Square well maybe the
only idea I can see about putting the
bishop there is to take the Knight I
mean that that's the only kind of
logical continuation and then try to
go for another weak porn because at the
moment we're only talking about the pawn
in front of Black's Queen but maybe you
can create another weak Pawn maybe you
can take the night I mean David you've
played a lot of these positions I mean
how would you play this as white I mean
I mean yeah I mean I've played against
and with the isolated Queen's porn I
grew up kind of uh for the first 15 16
years of my life I was playing with this
porn in a lot of my openings especially
with white side and then in later years
I like playing against it
um so yeah you're right Simon it's
always a question do you just kind of
blockade this Pawn do you play against
it long term or do you change the
structure and in later years I quite
like playing against this uh this
stretch and he actually goes for it I
guess the idea will be as you say to
attack this Pawn first of all and once
it's defended to try and occupy the
square in front of it just like you did
with the other isolated Pawn this is
slightly different black still has one
isolated Pawn over here
but uh okay we see this on the board
black has one isolated phone but these
types of they're not quite hanging pawns
they will be called hanging pawns for
example if uh they ever Advance
um we call these hanging pawns because
they're both kind of hanging there not
defending each other but uh the
alternative structure here if you can
blockade for example the dream would be
uh okay I'm gonna help white here
slightly but the dream would be to for
example uh occupy the squares in front
of them and locate them both and then
these two pawns are Eternal weaknesses
these two knights are just immovable
objects this is the dream but uh I don't
know what level of ronin has in mind in
the current position if we go back
how is he going to stop the pawn
advancing he offers a queen trade yeah
very logical actually in an end game
whose pawns are going to be weaker it's
probably blacks easy plan to double up
and attack
the base of the pawn chain yeah I mean
from my experience it's not necessarily
great it's not necessarily a big
Advantage but I don't think you're ever
risking anything with white in these
positions and uh I'm not sure whether
Avenger will go for the queen trade if
he doesn't then he's gonna have to put
his Queen a very passive Square
so yeah it's looking quite good for
Iranian right now there is also a threat
of taking this Pawn if antrik first gets
rid of his Bishop that Bishop was in
danger of just being a bystander and not
really helping out now we see a trade of
queens and Black's night leaping into
the center hitting this Rook whoops my
arrows today a bit off he's hitting this
Rook and uh this Rook has a question to
answer do you go across to Target
another weak isolated porn or do you
just take a step back and double up with
your other Rook when the opportunity
arises he does go after the weak Pawn
that's very ambitious by aronian
what do you guys think how would you
estimate White's winning chances
I mean it looks like he's doing all the
right things I mean as long as Black's
pawns don't move forwards they're always
going to be a bit weak and white can
attack those Pawns of his Rooks and his
Knight coming into the center so I'd
want to try to blockade those pawns and
gradually build up against him if I if I
was white here so maybe I can move my B
Pawn fours or move my Rook over
something like that but I think if black
can move the pawn uh you know the
backwards Pawn forwards then he should
be okay so he has moved there he has
tried to stop that pawn from moving and
it's just Black's Pawn's a little bit
weaker and white spawns and that means
in the long run white has this uh
Advantage yeah yeah but one thing there
is one consequence of pushing your Pawn
that's uh that to that square and that
is and this is this move that the Knight
jumps back and is ready to spring
forward to the C4 Square which means
that you must always that night the
White Knight must be within guarding
distance of that square so I'm guessing
that he's going to
I was going to say step back but no I
like this idea much more step forward
and Target the weakness
Yep this is the weakness and Black's
night jump attacking The Rook attacking
the porn I guess we'll be met with a
simple move by the white Rook and again
pressure on this guy two pieces
attacking it now if you march forward
the problem is you are overloaded this
black Rook is tied down defending the
spawn and this pawn and after an
exchange white would win a pawn uh this
guy the a pawn might decide the game so
right now yeah it feels like a Rooney's
putting the pressure on adventure it has
to be really accurate to defend but he
doesn't pause he moves his Rook across
something similar might happen for
example what my step is Rook forward
first or bring this one into the game
and it's all about the pressure on these
two pawns right now it looks really nice
though to have two Rooks behind a pawn
and an open Line could that pawn become
a star for evanchook it could but at the
moment it's not an open line and uh here
we see that this Pawn is prevented from
moving the square in front is guarded
three times by white pawns and pieces
it's only protected twice by Black's
Rook so these Rooks could become very
very good if this Pawn suddenly
disappears ah but at the moment they're
just passive they're stuck defending so
actually once the pawn off the board
yeah you want to trade it off you don't
want to lose it for free but uh yeah if
you can somehow trade off these two now
then
should be okay so the plan is not to
have that pawn March up to become a
queen
a deal ideally yes but its path is
blocked unfortunately
this potential Queen yeah it's miles
away from Coronation at the moment I
wouldn't be surprised to see uh
levonaroni and kind of centralize his
King just as Evancho is doing or maybe
start attacking the pawn now
can you win this Pawn even
oh it looks great it looks good doesn't
it it looks like you can go for it well
you have to put the Knight maybe in the
way don't you yeah but it just looks
like Black's under a lot of pressure
here
um at the moment and this as well it's a
very interesting idea here by Liv right
but but I'm not sure about it because
he's not planning on taking the pawn
because
then he would be doing Black's hard work
job for him you know he might be
planning on taking it I'm not sure I
mean for example a black weights
what is White's plan is the idea just to
trade off and then just start pushing
and just trying to make use of this kind
of two versus one majority
uh maybe this two versus one is going to
be the potential winner for white
yes Black's traded off one weakness but
he's still got two isolated pawns it's
more than before
yeah it's really interesting uh decision
now ahead of level does he trade off and
try to make use of his Pawn advantage
we should mention black couldn't take
this Pawn on the last move because the
Black Knight would have been loose and
uh would have been captured so Iranian
in the moment
he has to take or he has to wait
ah I don't know I'm just not a fan of
this move by Lavon
I just think that those two Rooks were
kind of blocked in by their own pawn and
yeah if you take it and you do manage to
win a pawn then the black Rooks are now
free and they're able to generate
counter play yeah I guess he felt he had
to do something ironic maybe he just
didn't see any other way to make
progress on the same as you I would have
probably waited maneuvered a bit but
maybe the moment would have passed in
that case
maybe Lavon thinking that this is his
best practical try at least
if Andrew looks super calm I would be a
bit stressed if I were black I must
admit yeah
strangely when you do have an advantage
you don't you don't really need to
change the pawn structure as you kind of
taught me you might as well you might as
well play around forever I mean I was
thinking this move to try and you know
push the pawns forwards and the the
neighbor of it going one square fours as
well but it does seem strange to change
the nature of the position when you have
an advantage and you haven't done
everything else possible first so and
kind of with you guys it's a bit of a
weird decision but this has a clear idea
now and he wants to move the other Pawn
forwards one square getting very nice
majority in in sort of the king side
middle middle of the board so the white
king also has a clear path towards the
center now which is nice a nice bonus
it's very hard for adventure to even
find a move to be honest Black's night
is stuck kind of plugging the C file
it's black Brooks are stuck defending a
pawn that's King can't really go
anywhere
yeah actually the more I look at it the
more I quite like it uh Evancho
meanwhile talking to himself calculating
Maybe
yeah just trying to come up with some
inspiration
kind of feels like his position is a bit
too passive really he needs to try and
get some activity I mean it's so hard to
defend passively and he he is he is now
going for something so he's doing what
Kaya said actually trying to use those
Rooks trying to push the pawn so uh I
hope he's not tuning in to our
commentary yeah I think this is a good
decision otherwise he was just going to
get suffocated now
I mean
the first thing is that white does have
the opportunity to win a pawn
yeah so
the pen can white win a pawn right now
there's this nice box of balls and
pieces and something has to be done
about them so which Pawn do you want to
capture Ivanka uh I guess it's this one
because the White Knight is attacked
yeah we have to take that one and then
that obviously Rogue takes Pawn but yeah
I kind of forgot that the pawn on e4 was
also hanging so you need to take
decision there first so there's no time
to go capture this Pawn because white
Central Pawn would suddenly fall yeah
that's I guess that's what's changed in
the last couple of moves blacks Rook
suddenly defends the Knight so this Pawn
is free to move and here white has to
decide do you take this Pawn
and I think black can safely retake it
feels a bit awkward this pin but it
looks like you're okay for now the
option for white is to step forward I
guess this is what irony was planning
with his previous
Pawn push these two pawns look good
might be able to step forward a bit
later as well still a weakness here
but black has got rid of one pawn and uh
okay even if you have to take your time
out to defend this guy now at least
you're more active than you were yeah I
like it too for a van Chuck it feels
like he's found a way to alleviate the
pressure
okay yeah current position Iranian big
decision to make
we must win for Evancho and probably I
must win for Lavon as well in this final
game and the preliminaries uh the
scenarios are many or who will qualified
and especially around that crucial
eighth place so giri probably also must
win for him the bar is over to his side
in his game against Arjun aragaisi Voit
check he is around that crucial eighth
place as well but all the way over to
his side so that is dramatic for both
Lavon and a niche on the same score as
no sorry Vita Checkers on 16.
so he can end up on 19. probably not
enough for him Christopher you it's not
looking too good for him against the
Liam Leia Christopher also done on 18
points and Navara is also fighting he is
currently the player in eighth Place bar
roughly to the middle maybe slightly
over to his side against the gelfand and
then Neiman looks like he is winning
against young Christ of Duda Neiman he
has qualified for The Knockout stage but
the Duda not 100 safe this could be
dramatic for him could do that be
knocked out by
than maybe two of the players on 18
points Prague looks like he is winning
his game against Ivan sarich so uh
Prague
looks safe to qualify but it's
impossible to say right now he will
probably take the two final spots in The
Knockouts then
yeah it looks likely that between 7th
and 11th Place yeah those five players
two of them will qualify
so it's two from five wow it could be
anyone I'm looking at the games right
now and it's it's hard to call Duda is
losing but still uh fighting so he has
some chance to save himself but uh for
the others it's must win simply Iranian
knows it's must win Navara Christopher
you Anish
so close I mean it could come down to
some tie breaks as well possibly and I
think the tie breaks is on individual
scores first of all between the players
but yeah head to head for the players on
the same score then it's number of wins
and then it's uh something crazy for the
future if you can I mean tie breaks
always so complicated yeah there's
always issues with whatever tie break
you decide to say I mean yeah if Duda
draws and everyone on 18 wins we could
see five players on the same score oh
wow and then I mean imagine the
head-to-head trying to work out who
scored more against that we need our
calculators so we need our stats man
yeah is it is there still a chance for a
Neiman versus Magnus final
it doesn't look like it but it's uh not
very unlikely that they will be on the
same side as of the brackets and
potentially face off in the semi-final
okay
okay yeah if Neiman is fourth or fifth
in the preliminaries they will be on the
same side of the brackets
third even
that's what I mean
we see a Neiman Carlson final that's a
final that's what I was kind of thinking
yeah that would be that'd be interesting
yeah yeah for the drama I'm sure yeah
and talking about drama Kaya have you
ever thought about announcing like who's
qualified as in like the X Factor you
know how how they used to line them up
and they used to step forward ah you're
safe
very brutal yeah and you could see the
chess players who really want it
problem is they're much smarter than me
so they would have already calculated
who's through yeah you could reveal to
the audience yeah you are the weakest
link but maybe you think if they didn't
know the tie break yeah like for
instance which one was going to be the
deciding one that wasn't announced and
then
or how about we do it like in America's
Got Talent and we all have our ex and we
can say you're out
oh but then we could have a Golden
Ticket like if you really wanted like
Yvonne Chuck for example yeah I want him
in the finals fantastic game every
season you could uh golden ticket to a
final but you'd have to knock someone
out it'll be a bit unfair
yeah sorry sorry Magnus at this time
meanwhile the game has changed slightly
and Ivan truck his chances are minimal
now but he might play spoiler for
levonaronian because he's given up a
porn at ventric but he's gone active and
look at this Blackboard now marching
forward White's Rook tied down stopping
its advance
and yeah it's just looking very
difficult suddenly the white light is
very very passive that white Pawn on the
edge of the board the white apron ready
for picking off at some point the black
Rook can go for it
I think if Android's active enough this
is great end game technique uh from such
an experienced endgame player and he's
just going active he gave away a pawn he
didn't want to sit there and negatively
defend now all his pieces are perfectly
placed level uh evantric interesting
game one game has finished Adib a draw
both of them knocked out of the Julius
bird generation cup
but most of the other players in here
fighting to qualify most of the games
have players
fighting for two final spots in The
Knockout stage
yeah it's uh looking like haronian he is
one of those players but he's gonna need
a helping hand he's going to have to
hope that other results go in his favor
because the more I look at it the more I
think if antrix just what if what a
setup he's found with his uh Knight rook
and pawn maybe we can jump in just to
explain why white uh being a pawn up
this extra Pawn is maybe not winning
right now uh I just can't see a move
actually for white uh any productive
move this Rook needs to stay behind the
pawn to stop it advancing if the Rook
moves away for example there might be
trouble this Pawn could advance and uh
counter-attack against the White Knight
this looks very scary so if you can't
move that piece you don't really want to
move this Knight
maybe you could make an argument for
moving it away
and then re-centralizing it later
what about the king coming forward
what would black do here
seems the most logical with the King
coming forward is if you can try it out
Bring it towards the center uh possibly
I think that problem for irony is you
know if you get some pieces pawns
exchange you get to a drawn Brook ending
so maybe now with this last move he's
like right okay I need to get my knight
into a position to create Frets against
Black's King and that that does seem
logical but it's a loud black to move
this Knight and and Black's Pawn in the
middle of the board is ready to roll uh
but the Knight now defending it so but
okay I mean aronian had to take risks
and uh you know just yesterday you have
to be careful here
I love what evanchuk did because uh
Lavon actually had a serious threat of
putting the Knight into the center now
that's not possible it's been stopped
and
still there's no way for white to really
come forward
I mean if this Pawn steps down suddenly
this Pawn is up for grabs later so you
can't really move the king uh if you
move the king this Pawn Falls with check
and black is in time to save his rook
and his Knight by going back
looks like black is better if anything
here because of this very very strong
protected past Pawn so I'm assuming
Adventure will go for this you can make
an argument maybe for the black king
coming as well what else could black try
you don't even need to rush this Pawn
looks very oh sorry my arrows uh this
ball looks very safe right now I mean I
mean is white threatening to come in
with their King I mean there is the
thing the like the black group can just
keep checking so it's not going to get
anywhere ambitious but yeah if black
were feeling
like they could play for more yeah maybe
a ventric has some winning chances what
a turnout it would be if eventually wins
this game and qualifies oh wow but can
he still qualify I mean everyone else to
lose uh in front of him pretty much yeah
it's kind of I mean even if he wins it's
very unlikely
um we can dream yeah he can dream uh I
mean he would over uh he would overtake
aronian yeah uh maybe a move like this
king move or pawn move uh but yeah if he
wins eventually he would overtake
Iranian he would need Christopher you to
lose Navara to lose uh Anish to lose wow
and then he's in yeah well stranger
things have happened yeah I I mean it's
just the Deep Pawn is very strong isn't
it and uh uh white White's pawns are can
drop off as well at the you know at the
wrong moment there's many tempting moves
that aren't there I mean moving the king
makes sense that pawn push uh yeah I
mean what's he gonna play he's now I
think realizing he's got some chances
here
um pushing Harry yeah I like it as well
I like pushing Harry but um I mean
I and I you know we could kind of
mentioned that white was thinking
potentially of introducing the king into
the game but but is perhaps the idea of
advancing the F Pawn something to think
about
yeah advancing the F Pawn there are some
checkmating ideas for example if the
pawn steps forward maybe white has time
too much forward to just utilizing some
Checkmate ideas so I'm not sure whether
it's good or not but that was my plan in
some trouble yeah we're seeing this chat
Mate work work already aren't we and uh
in a previous game yeah
it's called back
back
off it was the King sitting there on F6
it's actually called box mate I never
knew that hat that one had a name but it
does so this was one potential idea for
white
what's this Checkmate called is this
also the boxmate for example
uh the king is trapped or is this just a
back rank looks like a back rank also a
background Checkmate so Black's King
actually in some potential trouble so if
Andrew decided to push his Pawn this
Pawn will act as a distraction at the
very least if white tries the same white
goes for this plan pushing forward
still some question starts actually for
the black king I think this is what
Iranian should try or what he will try
just because these pawns look dangerous
you don't really want to capture and
allow white tonight into the dream F5
Square he hasn't played it doesn't play
it that looked very natural to me but he
dropped back instead I mean it's a bit
strange going passive like this for the
night as well but I mean he's keeping
Black's Pawn on the lock and key here
that that pawn is is now going to
struggle to come forward surely black
now just brings the king or something
like this but it's uh
still a lot going on here free results
they're all available as always and um
let's play it should be a draw but these
are two humans it's a rapid game plenty
of chances for both sides and uh that's
dramatic when you look at the bar in
Anish Geary's game it's all the way over
to his side he is one of those four
players on 18 points so a winner will um
we'll put Geary probably maybe in the
quarterfinals of course depending on
results in the other game this one for
example in the Magnus Carlsen camera
game the bar is slightly over too Karma
aside actually is Magnus in trouble
there and actually before this round
Magnus had a performance rating in the
tournament of 29 28 even after losing 15
rating points against Niemann using that
game 29 28. yeah close to 3 000 in
performance rating the road to 2900 yeah
I I was just gonna share with you a
picture because I feel like there's so
many things that could happen that
there's so much excitement going on all
over the boards but I kind of like the
way that I'm fat Max is watching the
show he says uh not enough tablets for
so many Fantastic games they've got them
all
impressive that's just stupid you can't
you can't look at that many games can
you or maybe you can you can you can
yeah well there is there is a tab isn't
there just 24 we can just switch Yeah on
one screen as well so you know I have
them all on one screen right actually I
do like that actually now the more I'm
looking at I'm thinking yeah I could be
looking at like exactly there's looking
at that yeah without moving my arm and
the lazier the better right so yeah I
just had to move my eyes yeah actually
that is good I'll change my mind I once
had uh one computer screen with the
chess on one with the football on one
with the tennis and then the other one I
was like doing some work on that's yeah
a little managed to work
like three words I'll do it later okay
so yeah there is a lot to pay attention
to right now who knows who will qualify
there are plenty of players in
contention especially for two spots
because it does look like young crest of
Duda is losing to Hans Neiman
so that means two spots are up for grabs
in the quarter finals
yeah I've taken a look at the giri game
it looks like he's in control and should
win that one okay uh barring a miracle
Escape by Eric icy so giri might be in
line to take one of those two spots
good for all those Geary fans out there
yeah according to Ty if both Gary Neiman
and Prague wins Barth all the way over
to their side in their games a 93 chance
to qualify for Anish but of course stuff
can happen in the other games as well
and this one the bar has been over to
Yvonne Chuck's side now went down a
little bit now though it went over to a
site slightly I guess it's because
Black's Pawn in the center was so strong
but now he's offering it up he's giving
his Pawn away in order to transition
into as Simon mentioned earlier a drawn
rook and pawn end game uh so if White's
night goes and takes this black pawn
which it doesn't
aronian playing with fire there it looks
like that pawn could run through but uh
yeah if um if that pawn was captured we
would have seen a trade of knights
Black's Rook would have gone and won
those white pawns on the right and it
would have ended up as a draw everyone
shaking his head there
yeah I mean because it's got some
chances and I guess he realizes that he
he has to win this game and he's like oh
hang on a minute I don't actually have
any winning chances you know if if uh if
Chucky plays the Right Moves and uh
Chucky's I don't think Chucky's thinking
about you know this is a thing with
Chucky he's not thinking about winning
or drawing or anything he's just trying
to play the best moves you know he's
just like you can see he's just a pure
person isn't he you know he's just a
Pure Chess player he just wants to play
the best chess you know uh he would have
played the opening he did I think
otherwise if he really desperately
wanted to win and if Gary wins this game
uh Evancho will be eliminated
but it doesn't even check almost have a
draw so I'm thinking the first move to
initiate this draw would be um to move
the king
are we the black king yeah move the
black king and uh the whole idea is that
say that white pushes the pawn I don't
see any way for the white king to
approach so yeah then the The Rook will
come down
and uh Once a Night yep and threatened
to promote and you can't this was the
this is the reason for the king move you
can't really
capture the board yeah capture the porn
but maybe yeah yeah because suddenly you
get pinned uh in one of two ways and
then that white knight would drop
um this one yeah some winning chances
for black uh I guess the idea here would
be that the White Knight defends from
this angle I think this is his plan to
cover the promotion square but it's
really hanging by a thread instead event
chose a different path he didn't move
his King which looked very natural he
brought his Rook across to try and
eliminate this pawn and whoa oh hang a
minute is this a blunder has Lev just I
think he has look at his reaction yeah
has he I mean no I think it was should
be fine right
should be a draw still but it's
important porn though yeah very
important point that was the only past
Pawn that Lev had
and um
I don't know I mean what I mean I could
see the bars saying it's in the middle
why isn't black just a lot better now we
should explain that after Rook takes uh
Pawn White's Rook now it looks like it
can take the Black Brook the Black
Knight but it's tied down stopping this
Pawn promoting so this is what we call a
deflection tactic if the black Rook is
captured black makes a new Queen and uh
it is captured wow he lets the queen
appear on the board but now Adventure
he it feels like he's winning they're so
loose these pieces she feels like you
should have a forced win here even you
know is there a full swing like nearly
Queen C2 is nearly like Shaq Hit The
Rook the white King has to defend itself
he has to drop a piece how uh no I I got
a bit enthusiastic there yeah right now
it's hanging by a thread
um okay wow look at this stockfish says
there's only one in winning move and it
does start with the most natural move
Simon mentioned it this track hitting
the white king and hitting the Rook
uh so you can force the white king to
come forward to defend its Rook I wonder
what's next because the first move is
obvious but he needs the follow-up
I'm struggling to see it it looks like
you can give a check hitting all the
white pieces but the White Knight leaps
to the defense blocks
is the idea that you go
this way oh this is hard this is
extremely hard you hit the Knight and uh
this Knight can't be defended if the
Knight moves then you go into the corner
and you use this angle and you win the
White Knight after it blocks
I don't know if he's gonna see this this
check next move you win the White Knight
this is what the computer thinks but
human point of view incredibly tough
yeah because if you don't want this
tactic then then it should be a draw
should be a draw because all the pawns
are on the same side and we had this
ending yesterday if you're watching the
commentary
um and that was a draw with Chucky
defending against Magnus Carson with the
rook and Knight vs queen and the way
you're supposed to draw this you've got
to keep your Rook your king and your
knight all defending each other all keep
them close to each other so if white can
get that set up there should be no way
black can get through but Davis pointed
out quite an amazing line there where uh
where White's pieces are just a little
bit discombobulated uh and they can't
defend each other and uh take a look at
Chucky he's in Chucky mode he is a
genius he's capable of finding this yeah
to be honest I'm not sure I would find
it even with 15-20 minutes on the clock
let alone uh let alone Chucky's three
minutes I wonder how this changes things
if Chucky wins I mean can he still
qualify someone say yes yes but but but
no one on 18 points can win and of
course it looks very good for Anish
Geary 19 points to win so if any of
those wins a win will not be enough for
everyone shook but of course we know
anything can happen in chess Miracles
have happened on the tour before
um Chucky this is why as well he's such
a great player he always pauses at the
critical moments and he censored it that
deflection tactic was nice I'm surprised
the Ronnie went for this so quickly he's
still had plenty of time but uh that
that Queen C2 and then the line you just
showed David the move is the hardest one
incredibly hard to see because and again
the only way you'd see this move is by
doing that tactic I mentioned time and
time again what is my opponent going to
play next if you're only thinking about
your own moves and trying to force the
situation then you'll never see this way
of playing and one key thing to become a
better player is just you know get in
that habit what's my opponent going to
play next what move can he possibly play
in I think it might be worth showing
that again David don't you because it's
that second move which is a real really
hard move but what a beautiful move it's
like a study actually the geometry right
it's a check it's a double attack you
force your opponent's move so the first
one's obvious but here it's process of
elimination as well from Chucky you see
that this check is back where you came
from doesn't help oh he doesn't find it
this check would have been blocked but
uh this was the winning move uh to bring
the Quinta this Square hitting the White
Knight the white Rook is still under
under supervision as well so the White
Knight has to move and no matter where
you put it there will be a disaster here
the queen can come into the corner and
uh at least you win some pawns I think
you could one win the night there as
well David yeah but yeah you're right
all these lines are just very good
aren't they so yeah you win the night
you're right something even stronger you
in the in this way if the Knight goes
the other direction you check first with
a skewer the Knight moves and then you
win it on the next move with a check
this would have been winning if we go
back to the game situation he didn't
find it it was very tough
very difficult in that position so we
can forgive him with three minutes on
his clock
and now it should be a draw look at that
the bar all the way over to Christopher
you side now in his game against Liam
there he is also a player on 18 points
so if both him and a niche
WinStar games we have to check Head to
Head scores between those two
so hard to work out isn't it what's
happening there was a win for
Christopher you okay so that would put
the 15 year old through wow yeah and
Judo now will be regretting not playing
a more solid game because both
Christopher you and Gary are going to
LeapFrog him aha
I mean nobody expected that we thought
doodle was almost safe
uh meanwhile back at this game
it should be a draw but suddenly White's
got a pawn racing up the board
see another turnaround White's born
suddenly dangerous evanchook down to two
minutes
I don't think he's aware that he missed
a win it was incredibly tough to find
but he's got to recompose himself now
and somehow stop this white porn
do you think aronians told to win
um it'd be interesting no it's really
really hard I mean it was it kind of was
a very hidden win and I mean David saw
it but I mean maybe computer nudge to
maybe yeah if I didn't see the
evaluation bar I would have probably
played the same movies but who would
have thought I mean that is actually I'm
going to remember that one and show if I
ever do any lectures because it's one of
those ones where it's just a little move
which doesn't seem to do anything the
only way you can find it what is my
opponent going to play next and it's
yeah it's a really really nice little
move that one it's like stretching the
opponent's Army it's like your
opponent's defensive like this and then
you push him over yeah just uh but you
do it in a way by stepping away yeah
which is lovely so you're stretching
your opponent not by coming in but by
stepping away which is kind of like you
know it's very beautiful aesthetically
pleasing way of doing things yeah it's
almost unique I've never seen that uh
before I must admit very nice yeah and
one of the players on 18 points have
finished with a draw David Navarro a
draw against uh gel fund so 19 points
currently in in eighth place but it
looks very likely that either
Christopher you or Anish giri will win
maybe both of them so 19 points should
not be enough for David Navarro
yeah and the tour before we've seen 21
is usually the golden number
occasionally you even need 22 but this
tournament is going to be 21 and you
guarantee yeah almost and what what
about Prague because I mean I've kind of
lost track of this course a little bit
can qualify is he qualified he's
qualified he's qualified already he's
not safe yet but he needs to score in
this game right okay if he gets a draw
then probably qualified we can have
several players on 21 points but I mean
the bar very much over to his side in
that game yeah but if Craig loses he
might be out yeah so much time for
Evancho seconds okay he made a move with
two seconds left but things are turning
again suddenly uh this uh black king is
a blockade for this white Pawn
but he's running out of moves now
evanchook this night move is really
hinting at the fact that white wants to
get his Knight if that Knight can give
one check is game over for black king
it's not happy where it stands but okay
if I'm trick here he can probably just
force a draw by giving a check with his
Queen bringing it back to the center
hitting the white king
White's King rook and Knight it's like
you said earlier Simon they protect each
other now so it's safe and what what's a
move by Iranian
and he's just saying take the Rook
because the mic is going to jump to the
D6 square and Fork everything and now it
just looks like it's winning for white
what what happened
excuse me for all Chucky we have to show
this in action replay just backtracking
a couple of moves a check the white king
moved another check and I thought this
was the draw I think I thought the white
king had to stay protecting its Rook but
aronia said no I can abandon that Rook
if Queen takes rook and Knight check and
white will win the queen and the next
move and uh that meant that black had to
go back and uh pin the White Knight and
suddenly this is a key idea the White
Knight is pinned right now so black can
safely stay on this line but all he
needs is one track
so if you just got to find the right
Square for the king look at the bar yeah
ten just as long as the white king moves
to safety somewhere the the white king
can step out of the pin you just need to
be able to move the Knight so which way
do you go with the King this is what Lev
is trying to work out now he's got loads
of time where'd you go with the King my
own thing is to go to the middle right
up the board this one yeah it's just I
like it and he's a big threat there's
only one check here as well and that's
the only check that you know it's been
played and he's found it I think this is
the winning gonna win this night check
is going to dislodge the black king
white is going to make a new Queen game
over if vantrik shakes his head
poor Chucky hands now and he does click
that resign button game over
21